cómo
un poco
muchas gracias la publicidad que cambió
el mundo entero para siempre este título
así titulé esta plática y quería ver qué
les provoca que les provoca esto
si lo leen entran no entran quieren
escuchar más no quieren escuchar más
este
les provocó curiosidad puede ser
y bueno cuando me invitaron a
a dar una plática aquí está el logo de
te impone
y el eslogan nos impone más porque es me
hizo pensar yo como publicista
yo soy publicista yo hago campañas de
publicidad dije y de alguna manera me
meta en la vida es hacer ideas que valga
la pena difundir
pero al mismo tiempo cuando me salgo de
un poquito de publicidad digo qué idea
tengo yo realmente qué puedo aportar yo
que valga la pena difundir fue me puso
realmente en un aprieto me puse nervioso
y entonces me puse a pensar dije en mi
vida antes que la publicidad yo llevo 28
años siendo publicista pero antes de ser
publicista siempre estuvo la creatividad
toda mi vida estuvo la creatividad es
algo que ha estado siempre y hoy la
creatividad es muy valorada cuando yo
decidí desde muy chico no sabía que me
iba a dedicar pero sabía que iba a tener
que ver con la creatividad sea siempre
lo supe y bueno en esa época era muy
común decir que te ibas a morir de
hambre si te dedicas a creatividad hoy
está de moda local por un lado me gusta
por otro no porque me hace sentir menos
especial - único este
pero ahora parece que les si uno ve todo
el tema de la automatización etcétera
ahora parece que si no eres creativo es
como te vas a morir de hambre eso dicen
algunos futurólogos sobran platicas de
creatividad que es en lo que yo me
dedico probablemente hoy en día es de
los temas de los que maya más hay
pláticas pero me puse a pensar en mí
realmente empecé a pensar en mí que me
ha ayudado a una parte es la imaginación
una parte es todo este tema ese es un
tema muy amplio porque que me ha servido
a mí realmente para destacar en lo que
hago al hacer mi trabajo soy más
intuitivo que teórico yo realmente
a veces no sé por qué hago las cosas la
verdad lo que sí sé es que más que
creativo soy consumidor de creatividad y
esto es desde siempre y lo vi como una
justo una de mis este de mis
características cuando se habla de
creatividad muchas veces se habla de la
curiosidad pero no se profundiza mucho
en ella a mí la curiosidad me ha ayudado
mucho y por eso quiero hablar un poco de
ella curiosidad a mí la palabra
curiosidad no me gusta la odio me parece
medio superficial me dio teta no sé sé
que soy bien curioso no no no no me
gusta pero en realidad es muy importante
no esté la curiosidad es sólo una parte
de ser creativo como estaba diciendo
pero a mí me ha ayudado mucho aunque
estoy absolutamente enferma mil a la
creatividad estoy enfermo de curiosidad
me desde muy chiquito me pasa que me
interesa todo y quería saber de todo y
me leía todo
me entretiene me hace feliz forma parte
de mi vida pero también es una especie
de adicción una especie de cárcel la
mayoría de la gente ve este baix
coleando en facebook
le da click a lo que le interesa a mí yo
estoy en un problema porque todo lo que
veo me interesa entonces tengo que
decidir que me interesa más y que me
interesa menos van a abrir todo porque
no hay tiempo y no puede estar no puedo
estar leyendo cosas en facebook hasta
las 4 de la mañana todos los días este
es un ejemplo de como en mi vida me ha
ido llevando a adquirir este
conocimiento que al final me han ayudado
mucho en mi carrera y que ha aplicado la
publicidad de una u otra forma por
ejemplo un día había una película en la
muestra de cine muy joven me volví loco
entonces me metí en un curso de
apreciación cinematográfica y en ese
curso de apreciación cinematográfica
visitasen kane de orson welles y me voló
la cabeza y entonces la fui a comprar y
empecé averiguar sobre la película y
encontré un documental sobre la película
que me hizo ver que la historia de la
película era mejor que la película y eso
me llevó a volverme un fan total de
orson welles y me leí su autobiografía y
luego y así me voy y me voy siempre y me
pasa con todo hace poco en noviembre en
la feria del libro este compré por
primera vez en mi vida una novela
gráfica yo tenía muchos prejuicios
me gustaban y me volví loco empecé a
averiguar todo sobre novelas gráficas le
llegó una vuelo la cabeza me compré
todas llevo 15 novelas gráficas de
noviembre a hoy y es un poco así como
soy
me pasó con la música clásica un día
escuché el concierto para violín de
beethoven me volvió loco quise escuchar
todas las versiones grabadas que existen
ver cuál es la mejor cuál es la que me
gustaba más luego dije entonces me
gustan todos los conciertos de violín y
entonces escuché el de sibelius y me
encantó y el de tchaikovsky y me sigo y
me sigo y no hay más la música el rock
progresivo mucho tiempo me volvió loco y
era mi grupo favorito pink floyd este
disco es todavía no pero luego llegaron
los sex pistols y esa historia me
encanta hacer exactamente lo opuesto ese
disco ese disco es lo opuesto ese disco
pero a propósito no como una cosa que se
vio a besos realmente hicieron estos
cuates son virtuosos entonces vamos a
hacer un grupo de no virtuosos que
toquen súper mal porque apenas toquen y
que toquen muy básico este los otros
hacen canciones sumamente largas
nosotros
hacer ninguna canción de más de dos
minutos etcétera la música electrónica
me pasa que puede ser que algo no me
gusta entrada pero yo digo pge vean la
cantidad de gente que va un concierto
música electrónica que sienten porque
llenan un estadio escuchar la música no
entendía porque yo necesito entender y
necesitaba entender por qué llenan
estadios yo no puedo escuchar música
electrónica todos los días y hablar con
gente y al leer lo más que pude hasta
que lo pude entender me pasó lo mismo
con la ópera de esta película de andy
warhol dieron un ciclo en en la unam una
vez de todas las películas de andy
warhol y creo que fui el único que las
vio fue lo único que vio todas las
películas esta película son tres horas
de un cuento dormido no pasa nada más
pero soy el único que puede dar fe de
eso porque nadie la vio
este pero de andy warhol me volví loco y
entonces empiezo a leer sobre valerie
solanas esta feminista que le disparó de
diset week y las canciones que le
compuso bob dylan y me voy y me voy y me
voy eso enriquece mi vida y me hace muy
feliz pero no solamente son cosas
relacionadas con arte con creatividad
desde muy chico y vamos al doctor con
mamá me lleva al doctor y me encontraba
este tipo de revistas en los
consultorios y me ponía a leer y me
acababa estas revistas y a veces me las
robaba me la llevar a la casa revistas
de materiales o sea que absolutamente
todos los temas y entonces es muy
cansado que todo te interese entonces o
sea realmente no tienen usted ni puedo
recomendar que sean así porque es muy
cansado es agotador pero a pesar de que
la publicidad me interesa por razones
obvias es a lo que me dedico es mi
pasión es algo que he dedicado toda mi
vida pero trato de no leer ni de no ver
mucho sobre el tema para no contaminar
me esté yo creo que la curiosidad muchas
veces nace de la capacidad de asombro y
creo que no hay que perderla la tenemos
esa de niños
pero la perdemos muy rápido yo de
repente yo naturalmente no me esfuerzo
por tenerla
la tengo y lo que me pasa es que estoy
con más gente y vemos algo y veo que las
demás personas están normales y yo estoy
baja
este ya veces me siento medio güey no
digo porque no fui el único que se
sorprendió
este pero pero creo que eso te hace
despierta la curiosidad y la curiosidad
te lleva a conocer más cosas siempre te
lleva a descubrir cosas nuevas
la creatividad es unir cosas que nunca
antes estuvieron conectadas luego
entonces la curiosidad te da cosas que
conectar es materia aprieta materia
prima para crear pero además no te
aburres es la mejor forma de aprender y
también la mejor forma es aprender
porque entiendes otras formas de hacer
las cosas de hacer las distintas este
gracias a mi curiosidad e viajado mucho
conocido mucha gente haya podido lograr
destacar profesionalmente en la
curiosidad nace la observación y
observar el mundo que te rodea es
inspirador muchas de las mejores ideas
de la historia de la humanidad han
nacido de la observación y no observas
si no te interesa te tiene que interesar
pero la curiosidad no solamente sirve
para poder tener más y mejores elementos
para crear y para estar continuamente
inspirado
mi trabajo es comunicar es conectar
profundamente con cierto tipo de gente
es hacer reír o pensar o llorar o
reflexionar o convencer o cambiar de
opinión es mover a alguien a ser que
piense sienta o haga algo y la
curiosidad te lleva a ser empático
vivimos en una era de mucha comunicación
y muy poca empatía si ustedes ven esta
las redes sociales métanse ahorita a
twitter hay odio pero hay odio porque no
hay empatía porque no hay ganas de
ponerse en el lugar de los demás es
decir porque no hay curiosidad por saber
por qué tanta gente está del otro lado
del otro en el otro bando no nos
queremos entender no nos queremos poner
en el zapato del otro si lo lográramos
si realmente te pones el zapato de los
otros lo entiendes pues puedes
comunicarte y la comunicación efectiva
se da entonces no en comunicación cuando
cuando hay empatía hay magia
creo en la comunicación con empatía creo
que es como funciona como realmente
funciona la comunicación creo que es
cuando la comunicación es realmente
poderosa con empatía se puede hacer una
campaña que cambia el mundo entero para
siempre como era el título de esta
presentación con empatía se puede hacer
una campaña que salva el mundo vivo de
la curiosidad porque me permite hacer
piezas de comunicación que generan
curiosidad para la marca y el producto
de mi cliente esto es algo simpático no
realmente lo que yo tengo que hacer es
despertar la curiosidad sobre el
producto o servicio que está o la marca
que está ofreciendo mi cliente esté vivo
de para y con curiosidad mi trabajo debe
generar curiosidad y cuando la genera
genera también curiosidad para mi
empresa
o sea es algo muy chistoso pero cuando
una campaña realmente buena siempre hay
una pregunta hay una pregunta que nunca
falla hay una pregunta que siempre se
hace la gente que siempre ven la
publicidad buena y siempre sigue quien
la hizo entonces además yo busco generar
curiosidad de quien hizo esa campaña
también porque al final así es como como
yo como hemos construido la agencia y
así es como hemos construido marcas
construyendo marcas hemos construido la
agencia
vivo asombrándome hablando de la
capacidad de asombro para asombrar a
otros y esa es la idea que creo que lo
vale la pena difundir quizás el mundo
sería mejor si fuéramos más curiosos hoy
la curiosidad se reprime un poco si se
ve en la curiosidad mató al gato y
regaña a los niños por querer saber más
etcétera etcétera
como cultivarla como promoverla como
sembrar las nuevas generaciones no lo
tengo muy claro
otra vez bueno obviamente se puede ser
más curioso por decisión no lo sé yo
creo que sí obviamente yo yo no lo sé
porque a mí en jonas y con eso y como
les digo estoy enfermo tiene su lado
malo la curiosidad te puede llevar a tal
vez a querer saber qué se siente hacer
ciertas cosas que no están bien pero ese
no es el punto hoy no este y yo soy
curioso y por eso prefiero estar donde
ustedes están y no parado aquí así que
aquí termino y me voy a sentar con
ustedes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]